[Music]
but the confession of the one who is
wicked
i am so is not followed by a reciprocal
similar confession
this was not what the judging
consciousness meant quite the contrary
it repels this community of nature and
it is the hard heart that is for
itself and which rejects any continuity
with the other
as a result the situation is reversed
the one who made the confession sees
himself repulsed and sees the other to
be in the wrong
when he refuses to let his own inner
being come forth into the outer
existence of speech
when the other contrasts the beauty of
his own soul with the penitence
wickedness yet confronts
the confession of the penitent with his
own stiff-necked unrepentant character
mutely keeping to himself and refusing
to throw himself away
for someone else there is here expressed
in its extreme form the rebellion of the
spirit that is certain of itself
for it beholds itself as this simple
self-knowledge in someone else and
to in such a way that even the outer
shape of this other is not
as in the case of a material wealth
something without substantial being
is not a thing on the contrary what is
held opposed to this other is thought
simply knowledge itself this absolutely
fluid
continuity of pure knowing which refuses
to put itself into communication with
the other
which in its confession had ipso facto
renounced its separate being for self
and thereby
superseded its particularity and in
doing so
posited itself in continuity with the
other as a universal
the other however retains within itself
and for itself its uncommunicative being
for
self and it retains in face of the
individual who did confess
just the same uncommunicative being for
self although the latter has already
thrown this
away it thereby reveals itself as a
consciousness which is forsaken
by and which itself denies spirit for it
does not know that spirit
in the absolute certainty of itself is
lord and master over every deed in
actuality
and can cast them off and make them as
if they had never
happened at the same time it does not
recognize the contradiction it falls
into
and not letting the rejection which has
taken place in words
be validated as a genuine rejection
while in itself it has the certainty of
its spirit
not in an actual deed but in its inner
being and finds the outer existence of
this inner being in the utterance of its
judgment
it is thus its own self which hinders
that others return from the deed into
the spiritual existence of speech
and into the identity of spirit and by
this hardness of heart
produces the disparity which still
exists
paragraph 667
is just as rich and and deep
in many ways as the preceding paragraph
666
in which this moment and movement
of confession took place which was
supposed to be
reciprocated and we might have actually
seen
the two different consciousnesses
representing we could call them
different gestalton different shapes of
consciousness
brought together and instead what we see
as we're approaching the end of
not just this particular section of
spirit but the entire
spirit section we see a
refusal a rejection
indeed a rebellion against
spirit by a certain misunderstanding i
was going to say a certain understanding
but really
a certain misunderstanding of what
spirit
is on the part of the
judging consciousness we
if we wanted to be a little facetious
here we might not just call it the
judging consciousness in english we
might also call it the judgey
consciousness people are often quite
worried
this is a bit of an aside in ethics
classes or intro to philosophy classes
about being you know what they view as
being judgmental
and they don't want to engage in moral
judgment
because they're be they're afraid of
being
i won't say the word judged here because
then it gets a little bit convoluted
being ascribe the status of being
judgmental or judgy and one of the
things that's very liberating in ethics
classes is i tell my students
hey i actually want you to be judgey
i want you to be judgmental i want you
to make judgments you just have to have
good
bases for doing so and you have to be
willing
to have your own judgments called into
question
not to just throw them out there and use
them to elevate yourself above
others or to you know push others away
or anything like that
but to genuinely engage others as human
beings and
interestingly we could say coming back
to this topic
that is what the acting consciousness
the confessing consciousness
did in fact do with its confession
right it took on the judgment made by
the judging consciousness
and said as hegel's going to tell you
here
i am so that that's me i'm going to be
honest with you
you know we have all these catchphrases
in our contemporary culture like
i'm not gonna lie to you you know i'm
gonna be like really
frank and open with you all these sorts
of things sometimes when people say that
they're actually bs'ing
they're putting on errors they're
putting on a front but sometimes they're
actually opening up and they're saying
yeah that is the way i am and notice
that this doesn't just happen
by the acting person by themselves
over on their side in their little
bubble you know
doing some self-scrutiny it requires
an other you know again a bit of a side
note but
self-consciousness hegel insists over
and over and over again from the
very beginning of the self-consciousness
section exists
in relation to an other you can't have a
self-consciousness
entirely by itself and that is what the
judging consciousness
is going to attempt to do by hardening
its heart and hegel here does in fact
use the term
you know heart to hearts right
the hard heart this is going to be quite
important well let's let's jump into the
text there's a lot more to say
along the way again this is a very rich
section there's a lot to explore here
but
you know we can we can go into those so
he says
the confession of the one who is wicked
the evil
or wicked consciousness the individual
the one who
acts and does so on the basis of motives
and intentions
that the judging consciousness says are
not only particular but selfish
right the there's a disjunction between
the action itself
considered in itself which would be
doing duty for duty's sake which hegel
in a couple paragraphs earlier said well
that doesn't really happen
um but maybe it does happen right
there's a disjunction there that's being
identified and the acting and confessing
consciousness has now
said yeah that's that's that's real that
is part of what's going on with me so
they made a confession and it's
the confession is i am so it's not
followed by a reciprocal similar
confession so
there's a judgment that's made right the
acting and evil consciousness
instead of persisting instead of
hardening
itself you know in in remaining
in its own point of view baharin
doesn't harden itself it doesn't create
a shell
it actually takes to heart the language
of judgment
it confesses i am so that's not
necessarily saying
that's all there is to me but it is at
least saying
yeah you're right about this you know
which opens up the possibility
for a reciprocity
now the other side the judging
consciousness
has the possibility of saying
all sorts of things in response and
there is an expectation here
on the part of the acting and confessing
consciousness
that the other person is going to behave
in a similar fashion that they're going
to say
well you know i myself let's say we're
taking
an example of like anger right i act in
anger i do something
that is uh mean-spirited but also
accomplishes
something good you know i see some
people being bullied and treated badly
and i i you know go and
act as a vigilante and beat the crap out
of the people who are bullying
okay now the judging consciousness looks
at me and says
you think what you're doing is is good
but really it's motivated by the fact
that you have a problem with anger
and you've got a little bit of something
out of beating these these people up
like you got to think of yourself as an
action star like all those movies and
video games that you play
or you got to discharge some of the uh
you know whatever
bully weight of bullying that that
happened to you back when you were
a child or make up whatever thing you
want
in involved in the judgment right so the
evil consciousness then says
yeah you're right okay so now what i did
was was good in a certain sense because
it prevented this other person from
getting hurt
and in a certain sense there's a little
cosmic justice in these jerks over here
getting their their you know teeth
kicked in
but i really wasn't doing it for the
right reasons
and maybe i'm just perpetuating the
cycle of violence and you know add
whatever other tropes you want in there
and now the the confessing consciousness
expects something from the other side
of the judging consciousness like oh
it's okay man
i've been there myself you know i really
struggled a lot with my
own misplaced anger let's
read let's read seneca's on anger
together and we'll talk about it
right that that would be some sort of
reciprocity
or it could be oh you know i i can't
relate to that
but you know i do have problems
with other things my anger isn't getting
in people's faces and
popping them in the mouth and saying
knock it off jackass
instead it's being passive aggressive
and like you know
recording people on a camera and then
posting it
on instagram or twitter and saying look
at this jerk
you know and hoping it gets picked up
and shared by
others or it could be well you know i
don't really actually have any any
problem with anger
but here's something about myself it
could even be
you know i was actually a little bit off
base
in how i judged you i i went a little
bit too far
i didn't think about what it's like to
be in your situation and to have to add
and we could
multiply examples of this
confession judgment expectation
and then something not happening over
and over and over again doesn't have to
be anger it could be
embezzling it could be cheating
on tests it could be slacking off with
work it could be anything that we want
so long as there's something where
a person is doing things and the action
is being
viewed from multiple perspectives so
he says um they're looking for a
reciprocal similar confession
this was not what the judging
consciousness
meant quite the contrary
so the judging consciousness was not in
engaging in judgment in communicating
that judgment to the acting
consciousness who then confesses
was not opening up this up to like let's
have a discussion
or i'm going to relate to you as you're
relating to me
they are withdrawn into themselves
there is a we could call it line of
refusal
here and there's going to be a certain
contradiction of wiersbrook
as hegel is going to talk about it later
on that is going on
within this and here we should think of
the contradiction
not in terms of aha gotcha you're a
hypocrite right we've already
gone through hypocrisy plenty in the
previous paragraphs notice that hegel's
not talking about that here
instead there's a there's too much going
on here for the story or the non-story
that the judging consciousness
is telling and the judging consciousness
is telling this story to itself
especially to itself also to the acting
and evil consciousness
and to whatever spirit happens to be
in this place so it goes on the
the judging consciousness repels this
community of nature
and is the hard heart that is
for itself and which rejects any
continuity any commonality any
equivalence with the other
so as a result he says the situation is
reversed a reversal is
taking place here the one who made the
confession
sees himself repulsed
and now this is quite interesting the
one who made the confession
acknowledged themselves as being bad
abusive
evil wicked however you want to
translate it
now we've already seen that the judging
consciousness
in the previous paragraphs is revealed
as being base
neither trichtica right pulling things
down
schlecked common bad in a certain way
but not evil bursa
but now it actually is being evil isn't
it
it is being wicked how so
by its very rejection he says
um the one who made the confession
sees himself repulsed and sees the other
to be in the wrong
why when he refuses to let his own inner
being
come out come forth into the outer
existence
of speech what's going on there
hegel is saying that there may be some
communication taking place
but what's happening on the part of the
judging consciousness who has already
engaged in communicative
whatever we want to call it it's not
quite action but it is communication in
the judgment
is now refusing further communication is
now
making the conversation if there is a
conversation going on to
to remain within the framework of
judgmentality we could say and
confession you know and and if there is
a response it's
yeah you are that bastard who is
like that and that's what's wrong with
you jackass
right instead of there being a oh yeah
i'm sorry that you know things are so
rough for you
or i can relate to you or anything like
that
happening so that's a bad action
that's a bad comportment on the part of
the judging consciousness
or at least a bad expression a bad
communication that's a non-communication
and so he goes on and he says
here we go he refuses to let his own
inner being come forth into the outer
existence of speech
when the other contrasts the beauty of
his own soul
the beautiful soul right with the
penitence wickedness
yet confronts the confession of the
penitent
with his own stiff-necked unrepentant
character
mutely keeping to himself and refusing
to throw himself away for somebody
else so this is interesting there's a
communication here
that is a refusal of communication that
communicates all the more by what is not
being done
by what is not being said to the other
this happens all the time doesn't it
it doesn't have to happen these dynamics
of confession and openness
and refusal don't just happen at this
point in the phenomenology they happen
in all sorts of people's lives don't
they and
in terms of how not just individuals
relate to each other but how groups
relate to each other you know
historic injustices have been done oh
you know
we're gonna make the the people who
suffered the historical injustices who
then have to act to like stay
alive or preserve their own their own uh
stories
we're going to make them into the bad
guys and we'll just hold back here
in a bastion of privilege and say those
people
you know they're no good well this
happens all the time
so he goes on and he says
um mutely keeping to himself and what
we've got here is the penitent
has his you know being confronted with
wickedness which they've already
confessed we see some other things going
on that we're going to get to
in just a bit and so refusing to throw
himself away
for someone else now does he have to
throw himself
entirely away no just open
the the hard heart a bit and so he says
there is here expressed in its extreme
form
the rebellion of the spirit that is
certain of itself
so it looks like spirit is on the side
of the judging consciousness right
that's the shape of consciousness that
matters the most
um it's a rebellion
emperor of spirit certain
of itself certain of itself you know
gevis
right is conscience this this whole
thing has been about conscience hasn't
it so this
this is the the the conscience that is
tied up inside of itself
and is asserting itself over
the other consciousness and refusing to
give
even an inch or an opening
and he says it's uh it beholds itself as
this simple
self knowledge in someone else now
notice it doesn't
here's where it gets a little
contradictory right it understands
itself as simple self-knowledge
but in itself no in in another
in its relationship to another in its
ability to
judge the other and thereby make itself
good as opposed to the bad and this is
quite interesting because
another way of translating ampurung
here is not just rebellious
rebellion or rebelliousness but
resentment right there's something here
that
actually in some respects echoes
or doesn't echo because it's before it
sort of prefigures what nietzsche is
going to call risantomont
using the french term for that and
diagnosed in works like beyond good and
evil
and genealogy of morals and other places
making the other bad so you can be good
right
so he goes on and he says
here we go beholds itself as this simple
self-knowledge in someone else and two
in such a way that the outer shape of
this other is not
as in the case of material wealth
something without substantial being it's
not a thing it's not
objectifying the other person
and making them into a mere thing it's
actually
you know treating them as the the
bastard the
jerk that they are only only a person
or something with agency can be a jerk a
bastard an
evil thing a thing by itself
can't be right so wealth can't be he
says
on the contrary what is held opposed to
this other is thought
thought on the part of this this judging
consciousness
simply knowledge itself this absolutely
fluid
continuity of pure knowing now here's a
key point
which refuses to put itself
into communication with the other which
in its confession
had ipso facto by that very confession
renounced its separate being for self
right and by the way there's there's a
terminological thing
here that's going to get lost a little
bit separate
and then particularity okay these are
both
coming from bizonder right
something that's individuated something
that has been made
on its own distinguished from other
things right so
the acting and confessing consciousness
has renounced not it hasn't renounced
being for self
per se it still has being for self right
it still is self reflective
otherwise it couldn't take a position of
oh man i actually i'm a bad guy
right or bad whatever um but it's
renounced
separate being for self it's no longer
persisting in that it's
it's not saying you know i'm a bad guy
and screw all of you i'm going to keep
on being a bad guy it's confessed it it
wants to
to make it right it wants to restore
connection to others right and by doing
so it supersedes
particularity now supersedes there is
um alfgholbin
right and so we have a dialectical
advance
going on here there's the dialectical
advance
really happening on the side of the evil
consciousness this is the consciousness
the judging consciousness over here
that's digging in hardening itself seems
to think that it's the one who's got it
all figured out
but really it's the action of confession
that is doing something doing something
new here
that's connecting it with with spirit in
a broader sense
so like it says it expressly
superseded its particularity in doing so
it posited itself in continuity with the
other
as a universal now did it make itself
into the universal
no it's saying there's something bigger
than the both of us
let's both confess let's both be honest
with each other let's both have this
reciprocity let's both have this opening
of being
towards the other and get to know for
maybe the first time
who we really are not just as
separate things but in relation to each
other in a relationship
within spirit that's what hegel's
calling spirit here and it could be like
within the framework of the individual
relationship
let's also understand ourselves in
relation to the
larger world that we're we're part of
right our families our friends our
communities
our history so you know of course i'm
reading a lot in here
i know but that's i think that's
something that you can read in here
so he says um here we go the other
retains within itself and for itself
it actually says you know retains in
itself on eem zelp zeke
within within itself right um
what does it retain its own
uh here we go the other retains within
itself and for itself it's
uncommunicative
being for self
now this is where it gets really
interesting
its own uncommunicative being for self
signs
nick mitchell thailand is zeke sign
right so frisian
being for self this has being for self
in a different way than this one does
right it's it's sort of like this is my
being for self
you don't get to talk about it you don't
get to look at it
i get to think about it whereas this one
is more open
right you can think about my being for
self you can tell me if i've got it
wrong
mid thailand is nick to me thailand is
not communicating
but also not taking part not
sharing right not not
giving a part of itself to the other
not giving any openings it
has hardened itself here so it says it
retains in the face of the individual
who did confess
just the same uncommunicative being for
self
it displays this being for self
that it has for itself in the face of
the other
which then can't really do anything with
it other than be like well this is an
opportunity we're losing out on and
i don't know why you want to be a prick
about this but you certainly are
uh i wish you would you know open up and
confess and turn to me but you're not
and he goes on and he says
though the latter already threw this
away it thereby reveals itself
now so this is a rebellion of spirit
certain of itself right
but this is actually losing
spirit it says it reveals itself as a
consciousness
which is forsaken by and which itself
denies
spirit so geist fer lassana
it's been forsaken by the spirit has
left it behind
it denies for loignenda spirit
it is in the process of denying spirit
so even while it's claiming to be the
the dominant the the right the the
proper thinking consciousness
spirit is leaving it behind and so it
says
it does not know that spirit in the
absolute certainty of itself which
which it thinks it has but it doesn't
really have
is lord and master the lord and master
is just meister
there aren't two terms there that's just
you know miller
adding in an extra term so meister
of what of every deed in actuality every
every vehicle kite and can cast them off
and make them as if they never happened
now that's not going to happen
here so much but it's going to happen
in the paragraphs to come at the same
time
it what is that it the judging
consciousness
does not recognize the contradiction the
wienersbrook
it falls into in not letting the
rejection which has taken place
now the rejection that has taken place
this is interesting right it's been
uncommunicative
but has it really been uncommunicative
no it's taken place in words
it has taken place through communication
there's definitely a contradiction there
you know it's sort of like when when
somebody is
on bad terms with you and you're and
you're like i'm not speaking with you
and they're like you're speaking to me
right now there's a contradiction right
that's the same kind of contradiction
as is going on here i am hardening my
heart against you i will not listen to a
thing that you say
and then they say something and you're
like i will not listen to that thing
that you said just there
well you're listening aren't you there's
there's a contradiction
and the hardness of the heart is really
quite silly
in in many respects isn't it so he goes
on
and he says um does not recognize the
contradiction it falls into and not
letting the rejection which has taken
place in words
be validated as a genuine rejection
well itself has the certainty of its
spirit
not in an actual deed but in its inner
being
and finds the outer existence of this
inner being and the utterance
of its judgment so it reiterates its
judgment
the the acting consciousness has already
heard the judgment
this is not new to it right
in some respects the the judging
consciousness
well it could have so much to say just
keeps saying the same damn things
over and over and over again and by
doing so it's
missing the opportunity and mistaking
the possibility of what what's there
so he goes on and he says it's thus
its own self which hinders that others
return
from the deed into the spiritual
existence of
speech and into the identity of spirit
and by this hardness of heart
produces the disparity which still
exists so
spirit is something that's bigger than
than
either side here and the acting
consciousness has at least gotten itself
to the point where now it can actually
be ready in spirit to have this mutual
recognition of the other
self-consciousness that has engaged in
judging it it's it's not even like
judging
and return the other self-consciousness
other than to say man you're kind of a
jerk you won't you won't actually like
even
accept my apology or my confession you
know
in any sort of spirit of of togetherness
or or honesty or openness you're just
like staying
within yourself and being better than
everybody else
but you're not being better than
everybody else you're you're you're
failing
in that respect and you're
being left behind by spirit
in the process
you